so liebe zuschauer letztes wochenende
haben die grünen mal eben geschichte
geschrieben mit deutschlands erstem
beschlussfähigen digitalen
programmparteitag wow da staunt die cdu
während sie noch versucht ihr mode manns
fax gerät anzuschließen
jetzt haben die grünen also ein neues
programm und sie wollen nächstes jahr
bei der bundestagswahl die union
überholen
wer die grünen
danke oma lindner union überholen das
klingt natürlich angesichts der
aktuellen umfragewerte ambitioniert
andererseits wenn frau merkel weg ist
kann das wahrscheinlich jeder über 800
grüne delegierte hatten sich von zuhause
zugeschaltet die parteispitze saß
derweil im berliner tempodrom wie in
einer filmkulisse also ein halbes
wohnzimmer bhutan geschwatzt wurde nicht
erinnerte look übrigens sehr an eine
bestimmte 90er jahre sitcom wenn sie
wissen was ich meine
mit lh beck und peggy bernburg
ungewohnte situation jedenfalls sondern
rein digitaler parteitag ganz ohne
publikum vor ort das heißt die beiden
hier mussten immer nur in die totale
stille sprechen wobei ich korrigiere
mich zwischendurch wurde es tatsächlich
auch mal richtig laut
ich habe mich gefreut als wir grünen 20
jahren kampf in göttingen die
südumgehung macht sie irgend wenn du
deinen eigenen ton ausschalten
es ist zeitversetzt deshalb vom bitte
nummer an liebe freundinnen und freunde
ich mich gefreut hat wir vor 20 jahren
in 20 jahren kampf in einem
bürgerentscheid die umgehung in götting
gestoppt haben und ich habe mich ihre
stellen auch man jetzt habe ich mein
internet kaputt gehauen
immerhin nach tagelangen abstimmungen
video schalten um trittin wutanfällen
haben die grünen am ende mit 96 prozent
zustimmung ihr erstes grundsatzprogramm
seit 18 jahren beschlossen mit dem
griffigen titel achtung veränderung
schafft halt ja mein gefühl sagt mir den
hat sich robert habeck ausgedacht
natürlich der gelernte philosoph
man sich natürlich kein schlechter
redner manchmal fahren rennt dass ich
vielleicht ein bisschen in seinen
metaphern um nicht zu sagen er neigt zum
schmuggeln
der gemeinsame grund unserer
gesellschaft ist ausgetrocknet
er hat risse bekommen und kleine scheuen
sind entstanden
auf diesen stollen leben menschen in
gruppen und grüppchen
wenn es aber stark regnet dann kann ein
solch ausgetrocknete boden all das
wasser nicht mehr aufnehmen
dann bilden sich einbildet sich ein
graben der das land in zwei hälften
teilt sicher meine werke dass nicht du
sitzt so gemütlich auf deiner schule und
plötzlich teilt sich der boden oder so
ähnlich man aber da musste derweil bis
zum bundestagswahlkampf mal deutlich
massenkompatible riss material drauf
schafft kommt zur punkt robert neulich
hat der discounter in dem ich hin und
wieder einkaufen seine regale oben
gebaut
man konnte nicht mehr längst durch den
magen gehen sondern musste quer laufen
ich brauchte doppelt so lange um meine
einkäufe abzuarbeiten und musste
permanent suchen und mich um orientieren
als ich dann an der kasse stand beispiel
dran und schlecht gelaunt
was hat sie denn die anekdote obwohl
warte mal das erinnert mich gerade total
an was was ich neulich im supermarkt
erlebt habe neulich laufe ich so längst
durch den discounter und merkel
plötzlich die haben ja umgebaut die
regale stehen ja alle quer weil wenn man
nicht völlig blöd ist findet man die
sachen ja trotzdem als ich also an die
kasse und der riesenschlange war ganz
vorne steht so ein unrasierter typ und
brüllt die kassiererin an mich denken
mensch das ist doch der habe völlig
durchgedreht wirklich dann hat er seine
drei kilo nackensteaks auf den boden
geschmissen und heulend aus dem rewe-
guelland komisch im fernsehen kommt ja
immer so sympathisch rüber ich schweife
ab
ich habe sozusagen also wir hatten fest
die grünen wollen stärkste kraft werden
mit diesem power du und einem
überraschenden programm
dass trotzdem und jetzt kommt in alle
richtungen anschlussfähig bleibt gebe
ihnen beispiel die grünen erlauben jetzt
doch gentechnik forschung für die
landwirtschaft lassen aber kaum die
nutzung zu ja sie sind für das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen aber nur
als leitidee als vision ist auch logisch
man will ja die cdu nicht verschrecken
sie sind für vermögens- und höhere
erbschaftssteuer sagen aber auch sicher
nicht wer die in welcher höhe zahlen
müsste
da ist wirklich für jeden was dabei aber
kommen wir zur entscheidenden frage wen
schicken sie denn nun ins kanzlerin
baerbock oder habeck wer hat da welche
stärken
vom hause her kommt er hühner schweine
weiß nicht was kühe melken
ich komme er aus dem völkerrecht ja da
ja dass liebe kinder nennt man subtiles
mobbing ich völkerrecht die schweine
können so nur frau tatsächlich soll ein
weiterer parteitag im kommenden jahr die
k frage entscheiden und ich sage wie
langweilig ehrlich macht das doch als tv
show und inas kanzler wer steckt unter
der maske wer ist das grüne aliens
airbag oder doch baerbock
wer regiert vier jahre lang unerkannt
deutschland naja bin ich robert oder
anna lena da kommt ihr nie drauf wer
erschreckt oper beiden beim staatsbesuch
fast zu tode rätseln sie mit um dann
2025 zu merken es war die ganze zeit
anton hofreiter dialekt kanzler
demnächst vier jahre lang auf prosieben
schade ich guck private und die dritten
die grünen wollen also stärkste kraft in
deutschland werden das land führen dazu
begrüße ich jetzt von den kreuzberger
grünen dörte hausten geschiedene
knieling dinge da draußen
das ist ja schon eine kühne ansage die
alte anlage partei will das kanzleramt
alt ist hier nur in sehr welke und zwar
ihre witze jede male gleiche schema
gespieltem erstaunen wort die grünen
wollen plötzlich regieren der tat mehr
den dinkel auslöser
wir grünen sitzen seit 1982 in
kabinetten aktuell in f
landesregierungen aber bei jedem
parteitag zeigt dir wieder den eigenen
fried der euro vorurteile bestätigt ja
das ist ein insektenhotel der können
käufer usw sich zurückziehen wunderbar
nachkommen bekommen und haben dann
bessere chancen auf den baum zu klettern
und dann sich die ganzen kleinen
blattläuse zu schlafen kommt schon das
schloss philipp hotels für ohrenkneifer
war ja mein gott das ist nämlich das
problem ja alterndem gegen fugees wie
sie klammern sich verzweifelt an die
klischees ihrer jugend als noch cool die
grünen zu wählen es aber nicht mehr cool
war es erwachsen was können wir denn für
eure mitglied kreises zeiten ändern sich
wir schmeißen keine steine mehr
sie haben gene haaren er er soll so
feierabend ich kann es nicht ändern
aber erstens habe ich die heute nur
ungeschickt gekämmt und zweitens da sind
ja doch schon eine menge faule
kompromisse in ihrem grundsatzprogramm
der rushhour starre bekommt womit
politiker war leider nicht kenne anderen
parteien ruft man vor dass sie
kompromisse macht nur den grünen warum
eigentlich
hier unser winfried kretschmann den
konnte immer strom die banalsten sachen
fragen der findet eben kompromisse zb
bei der weg sind sie für die glasflasche
die milch in der glasflasche wie nie ist
halt eher so der nachdenkliche noch
heute steht auch oft eine halbe stunde
vom milch regal und groove der tochter
fanta abwägen genau so wird man
ministerpräsident gut im er die sache
mit der milch finde ich jetzt auch nicht
so brisant
aber wenn ein grüner verkehrsminister
wie gerade in hessen die räumung des
dauerfrostes durchsetzen muss schöner
autobot das muss doch wie zum letzten
mal können sie den bittersten den 80er
jahre film in ihrem kopf als sie dann
ihrem jugendzimmer und darm heinz rudolf
kunze poster von wackersdorf geträumt
haben in den seltenen vix pausen heute
leuchtet anlass die a 49 wurde im
bundestag beschlossen und sollen
gerichten bestätigt ende selbst die
aktivisten sie sehen total entspannt
gerade menschen
gefällt damit eine autobahn gebaut wird
das mega unnötig in diesen zeiten so ist
doch super
dürfen wir sie vielleicht vectron
fräulein aber gerne doch ich muss
sowieso alle richtungen ja alles richtig
ich meine es gibt doch gewisse
grundsätze so ideale die müssten für die
partei schon eine rote linie sein
beziehungsweise grünen achtet hat doch
yakin zweck mit ihn akzeptieren sie die
realität bündnis 90 die grünen sind eine
ganz normale partei
und wissen sie was ich sage es ihnen
jetzt einfach mal bescheuerter outfit ja
die alberne mützen das ganze idioten
kostüm
dann zieht doch nur noch für die heute
show an oder glauben sie grimm private
um wahr sein so darf ich vorstellen die
grünen 20 20 und jetzt gehen sie mir
nicht im sack ich muss wie ein
aktiendepot umschichten
dörte dingsbums
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]